it's april 1st 2022 and i'm not going to
do any april fool's jokes on you in part
because i'm so busy that i don't have
the time to think up a good one and
you'll see why when we talk about what
we've got coming up in april and what
you might have missed in march i always
like to begin by talking about three big
things big thing number one
is this the silver
play button that that came in for
reaching 100 000 subscribers uh that
happened about a year ago but the the
award finally came in march so that's
kind of a cool thing to happen big thing
number two i am giving a talk on saint
anselm and divine simplicity and invited
talk by the new dionysus circle started
by one of my students so i'm really
proud to be asked to present and it's
going to be a great talk i'll talk about
that in the april section and then big
thing number three we started in march
but we're
ramping up in april and that is stoic
sundays where i'm going to be
talking on a sunday or two it'll be two
this coming month about basic ideas in
stoic philosophy and practice doing a
deep dive really you know digging into
the text giving people resources that
they might not be familiar with already
so that that'll talk about in both the
march and the april sections
all right what went on in the month of
march a lot of events almost all of
which were online but one of them was a
face-to-face talk that i gave at
milwaukee institute of art and design
where i work and it was a research in
progress talk where i discussed the
development of notions of flavor how the
four flavor thing that we all got taught
as elementary students of sweet salty
bitter sour is actually a sort of
reduction of the
many flavors that were recognized in the
western and islamic
traditions both in medicine and in
philosophy and in the culinary world
from hippocrates plato and aristotle
onward all the way up to the 19th
century so that was a big track that i
gave i also did a lot of events as usual
the you know ask me anything
session uh political theory and practice
we talked about the new york times claim
to a new right for people of free speech
i did my usual hegel sessions worlds of
speculative fiction
we did octavia butler for the classic
metal class we talked about parody in
heavy metal um you know i did my my book
readings from my book uh reason
fulfilled by revelation and we finished
up the book and we started doing that
new stoic sundays thing as well with a
talk on the
cardinal virtues and some great
discussion
you know i was involved in my usual
stuff i'm actually teaching more than i
was at the beginning of the semester
because i took over a class for a
colleague who had to go on medical leave
a writing class and so you know that has
been adding to my
workload i've also been meeting with
lots and lots of clients for tutorials
philosophical counseling consulting so
that has kept me busy
i did an interview with plato's academy
that i'll link to below and i've also
been doing a lot more writing in my
medium blog i'm trying to get more
writing accomplished and i
shot and released a lot of videos
including a video specifically on the
unboxing of this
silver play button award i got four
half hour hegel videos done for the
month
i
we also had wisdom for life show videos
show videos for that as well
on episodes 52 and 53 classic metal
class again we did parody and heavy
metal for session
17
and
worlds of speculative fiction octavia
butler that was that was a fun session
as well
i did a thing a video on the twitter
conversation about what has come to be
called the thread where an academic who
has an extraordinarily privileged
position was telling everybody else how
wonderful academia was and so many other
people weighed in and said wow is this
tone deaf in a time when most academics
don't have basic job security and don't
enjoy all these wonderful perks that
you're talking about so that was kind of
an interesting one
i did an aside video where
i
took a little excerpt out of one of my
half hour hegel videos and said hey
let's let's talk about this particular
topic i got a book review video done on
a long overdue book review on on a john
seller's work the art of living right
and i released a lot of core concept
videos on
augustine and the confessions which we
were covering in my medieval philosophy
class
podcast episodes um you know
i finished up the anselm sequence on the
monologian did uh five episodes on aj
airs language truth and logic then i did
a poll
and people were like um
do some well i did some cicero stuff and
then i did a poll and people were like
do kamu and thomas aquinas so i did some
you know clean up stuff on those getting
some camus things done getting some
thomas aquinas done then we're back to
cicero now on uh his work on the ends uh
book three which is about stoic
philosophy so a lot going on in the
month of march you know i got to see
my oldest daughter
once i think
she happened to be visiting you know the
our side of town with her her boyfriend
so we got together a bit
just mostly lots and lots and lots of
work this last month
what do we have coming up in the month
of april well it begins tomorrow with
two events one at 12 p.m all these times
by the way central time so make sure you
check your time zone i'll be starting
the month with my my usual ama that is
ask me anything session you can show up
i wouldn't ask the questions ahead of
time because it seems like youtube kind
of scrubs them right before the session
begins so you want to get them in early
in the session which begins at noon
central time then at 2 p.m a perk for my
patreon supporters uh i have my my
monthly philosophy chat that's a much
more intimate you know not exactly
one-on-one but but certainly smaller
group discussion where they can ask me
about anything they want in in
philosophy so if you want to do that you
might consider becoming a patreon
supporter
the next saturday the 9th at 12 p.m
we'll have our classic metal class scott
taruli and i are going to be discussing
metal power ballads and what makes
something a power ballad as opposed to
say an anthem or some other kind of song
and you know what are the what are the
really good ones out there what are the
ones that are too schmaltzy uh and and
we should avoid or not recommend
um on the 10th we'll have our first
stoic sunday of the month we're doing
two of them this month and we're digging
into basics of stoics philosophy and
practice we started off last month
looking at all four of the cardinal
virtues
for each of the ones coming up this
month and next month we're going to zero
in on a virtue and talk about what the
stoics have to say about it so we'll
begin with the most important arguably
of the virtues wisdom or prudence or
practical wisdom uh you know prudencia
in in latin phronesis in greek also
sophia so we'll be talking about that if
you're curious about stoicism in general
or
you want to know more you've actually
looked at it a little bit but you want
to know more about it you definitely
want to come to that session
on the 13th at 5 00 p.m we'll have our
public hegel q a and discussion
that is supported by my by the patreon
supporters of the half r hegel project
but anybody who wants to come can and
ask about hegel ask about philosophy
more broadly
on the 16th at 12 p.m we are going to
have worlds of speculative fiction
and this month we're actually doing
something a little bit out of the
ordinary we're looking at olaf stapleton
who was a british philosopher and
novelist and we're going to definitely
be looking at his work the first and
last men and then we'll see if we can
get into any of his other works and
these are kind of unusual in that there
are no actual characters it's like the
human race is the character in these uh
novels but they are speculative fiction
i'll also be talking a little bit about
stapleton's uh book on ethics that that
is uh germaine to this as well
on the 24th so jumping quite a bit ahead
at 12 p.m
again stoic sunday and we will be
talking about the virtue of justice and
going deeper into that as well
on the um
[Music]
the 26th
uh at uh
oh no sorry the 28th at 6 p.m the
milwaukee stoic fellowship we'll have
our uh monthly meeting we are talking
about stoic ethics going through
diogenes laertes
on the 29th the ant i'll be giving the
anselm talk that i was mentioning
earlier so it's on anselm on divine
simplicity
and the trinity and how how can a triune
god be simple and what are our notions
of simplicity it's going to be a great
talk i'm scheduled for two hours so
there'll be a lot of time for q a and
discussion it's kind of seminar style
being hosted by the new dionysus circle
which is already off to a great start
and so i would you know highly advise
checking that out finally on the 30th at
12 p.m we'll have our political theory
and practice discussion
that one is tba but i'm kind of leaning
towards thinking about you know more
questions having to do with freedom of
speech or frankness of speech but we'll
see where we go with that i will
announce the title or the topic
down the line
doing a lot of writing this month i'm
trying to bring out some online classes
as well some new some new things that
you can participate in
i'm you know i'm scheduled for doing a
lot of tutorials and client based work
my classes will be wrapping up for
milwaukee institute of art and design by
the end of april which means i'll have a
lot of grading to do around then
carthage will still be plowing ahead
well into may
videos you know i'm i'm gonna shoot for
getting at least four half our hegel
videos done this month we're making some
good progress getting close to the end
of the
phenomenology and of the project that
has been going on for eight years now i
need to get some more book review videos
done i'm you know a little bit overdue
on those i might do some personal like
the saddler stories videos or do some
some updates or things like that
and i will probably do some more of the
you know excerpting out asides
digressions rants and posting some of
those um core concept videos i shot an
entire sequence on alcoin of york the
carolingian renaissance
writer
his work on virtues and vices
which i released to my medieval
philosophy students and to my patreon
supporters but i'll be releasing them to
the general public coming up this month
i'll be doing some videos on anselm's on
truth which which i need for my my
medieval class i'll also be be producing
some videos on franz fanon's
black skin white masks that i didn't get
to because i'm teaching him in my
existentialism class so i'm you know
finishing out the series and then if i
can get to it i need to do some videos
on bernard of clairvaux
treatise on divine love uh but we'll see
if i can get to that that might be a
little bit too ambitious
podcast stuff i'm you know i've got some
more cicero to do some stuff on james
dickey
i think i'll probably convert those
lecture videos that i did recently on
prudentius's psychomachia
into podcast episodes and then we'll see
where we go after that maybe i'll do
another poll you know hey should we do
some of these some of these maybe i'll
just grab some some things that i did in
the past and never got around to turning
into
podcast episodes we'll see where we're
going from there but it's going to be a
busy month of april uh to finish out the
semester i'm kind of looking forward to
being free of academic classes which
will be the case until about halfway
through the summer when i begin teaching
again right
but yeah there's there's a lot of really
cool stuff on the horizon i hope you can
join me for some of these online uh
events and you know stay tuned for the
releases of online classes
that you can
sign up for and work on at your own pace
i'll be releasing some more stuff like
that coming this month and yeah a lot of
cool stuff happening it's a beautiful
time of year uh you know as as spring
starts getting underway here in
milwaukee so i'm sure you'll see a lot
of pictures if you follow me on social
media of the walks that i take and stuff
like that so hope you have a great month
ahead and i will see you at these events
or perhaps some of you in uh
face-to-face things here in milwaukee
you